well after eight years the minority
Democrats are as we said back in control
of the house that may soon have a new
leader of the House the Speaker a
growing number of Democrats publicly
voicing opposition to electing Nancy
Pelosi to that job for another time one
of the things that I talked about
frequently on the campaign trail was the
need to have new voices in Congress the
need to turn a new page we answer that
call for new leadership by reinstalling
the same status quo establishment
leadership that we've had in this party
since 2006
then we're letting down the American
people once we show that the leader
can't get to 218
you're gonna see other people throw
their hat in the ring too now there a
lot of ways Plessy could respond to that
the most obvious is by saying look we
just won 39 seats in the House possibly
we're gonna get to 40 I did that she
could say that instead she's crying
sexism you'd have to ask those people
what their motivation is I think of the
17 it's mostly like 14 men who are on
that letter if in fact there is any
misogyny involved in it it's their
problem not mine man toxic masculinity
in the Democratic Party Richard
Goodstein a living expert on this but no
just kidding but he is an attorney and
former adviser to both Bill and Hillary
Clinton joins us tonight I didn't know
we're should there was that much sexism
in the Democratic Party Nancy Pelosi
says there is what are you guys gonna do
about it
yeah I was sorry to see Nancy Pelosi
attribute these rebels to misogyny and
sexism I actually think she knows that's
not what it is that when Connor Lam was
running for election initially in that
district in Pennsylvania that went for
Trump by 20 and all these ads were being
run saying he was just gonna be a puppet
of Nancy Pelosi guess what he said he
wasn't gonna vote for her if he got
elected to be Speaker and you know what
he's not it's not because she is a woman
it's because he made a commitment to his
constituents because he basically
thought that's what he needed to do to
get elected and be what he thought was
right that the Democrats needed to turn
the page oh so he just wants the most
qualified candidate irrespective of her
sex
I can't let you off the hook that fast
Richard these the rules that you guys
wrote and the rules are as follows the
most important thing about you is how
you're born your sex your race your
sexual preference your innate qualities
your DNA that's what defines you it's
called identity Richard I don't know if
you knew that in the intersectional
world that you guys made you can't just
say oh we found a better candidate
you're blowing off a woman 14 men are
doing that is there an investigation
into institutional sexism in the
Democratic Party I'm dead serious why
wouldn't I yeah here's what's worse the
problem with the Democrats and I'm
serious about this it's nothing to do
with identity it's with seniority and
and they I think respect the fact that
when Newt Gingrich came in that the
Republicans did something different they
basically said we're going to put the
sort of younger vital able competent
people in our leadership position in
committee chairs and it Paul Ryan's a
young guy and I think that's something
that frankly a lot of Democrats wish
Democrats could figure out a way to
embrace it has nothing to do with Nancy
Pelosi's gender or or comes from Clarins
race it has to do with really then yes
but everything outside the Democratic
Party's leadership structure according
to Democrats has to do with race and
gender everything I mean every time I
flip on the tube there's some [ __ ]
tugging his chin and saying I don't see
enough people of whatever in this
picture I mean that is the most basic
democratic talking point but we're not
supposed to apply it to the Democratic
leadership because why well again I
think the Democratic talking points are
about health care about making sure the
tax cuts go to working people you know
about you know gun background checks
about infrastructure that's what
Democrats are uniting around can they
stop lecturing the rest of us about
racism and sexism since clearly they
don't hold themselves to the same
standard that's all I'm asking for
that's by the way I agree with I hope
the Democrats talk about health care I
think it's an important topic I think
we'd all benefit from that can they lay
off the race and gender stuff a little
bit though since they're obviously not
playing by those rules again Republicans
put Nancy Pelosi on the ballot all these
ads they ran against her Donald Trump
said himself he was on the ballot and as
you just said Democrats picked up 39
seats had nothing to do with ray
or gender having to do with sort of a
belief that a they needed an agenda that
the Democrat supported and be frankly to
put a check on don't you just a lot over
nothing to do with race or gender really
I mean or gender how do we know that so
here's what I know
here the stark facts of the case Donald
Trump is for Nancy Pelosi as Speaker but
Seth Moulton is not Trump is comfortable
with a strong woman in power Seth
Moulton clearly isn't yeah Seth Moulton
looks like a sexist to me by this
measure and Donald Trump seems very
enlightened and that's what I say why do
you see something different you're
assigning weight to what Donald Trump
says I think most Democrats and frankly
most people the country anymore don't
with all due respect they just don't
assign weight and what he said are true
I'm for Pelosi look I'm just using the
rules that you guys made up and in force
with Germanic efficiency on the rest of
us that's all I'm doing and how does it
feel it feels bad because it's unfair
and stupid isn't it can you just admit
that it's unfair and stupid and the rest
of us have to live like this in fear and
maybe you guys should live that way just
for a day to see what it feels like okay
you're ascribing things that I think
Democrats and public generally they
wouldn't have voted in to Democrats to
run the house if they accepted what your
your proposition I guess I don't know
why they did Richard seem great to see
you thank you I don't think we're sexist
I was just kidding thank you